vous êtes philosophe spécialiste de la
philosophie juive mais au-delà ou à côté
vous avez construit une phénoménologie
de la transcendance alors titre qui peut
faire un peu peur mais qui en même temps
portant lui une tension qu'on va essayer
ici d'expliciter ainsi qu'une promesse
nous traversons une crise climatique une
crise civilisationnelle qui semble
précisément appelé non pas des solutions
isolées mais un changement global
autrement dit un changement de paradigme
la tâche est immense est-ce que c'est
celle de la philosophie et d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer ce que
c'est qu'un paradigme la vaste question
un paradigme c'est je dirais un cadre de
pensée
global dans lequel va venir s'exercer la
rationalité et dans lequel vont venir
prendre place toutes sortes de débats de
controverse d'opposition de discussions
mais qui ne vont jamais remettre en
question le cadre lui dans lequel
s'exerce cette rationalité disons qu'un
paradigme c'est peut-être ça ce cadre en
lui-même ininterrogeait sans doute la
crise que nous traversons aujourd'hui on
le sent bien appelle un changement de
paradigme c'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit
d'une crise très globale qui se décline
en une multiplicité d'aspects et pour
laquelle on voit bien qu'il n'est pas
possible d'apporter des solutions
locales mais
qu'il s'agit d'une crise à laquelle la
réponse ne peut être elle aussi que
globale et ça serait donc précisément
cela un changement de paradigme alors
vous vous inscrivez plutôt dans une
philosophie critique à l'enseigne de
Kant est-ce qu'on peut déjà porter un
diagnostic sur cette crise et donc
justement éventuellement sur ce
changement de paradigme la crise
écologique n'est qu'un est un aspect
vraiment très massif mais n'est qu'un
des aspects de la crise que nous
traversons aujourd'hui mais si on devait
peut-être
caractériser la crise écologique en
regard de cette question du paradigme
alors peut-être qu'effectivement on
pourrait dire que
la crise écologique est d'une certaine
manière le symptôme d'une crise du
paradigme moderne du paradigme de la
modernité ce que je veux dire c'est que
on peut repérer la naissance d'un
nouveau paradigme
au tournant je dirais du 17e siècle à
l'époque d'un autre changement de
paradigme changement d'un paradigme
cosmologique qui est le passage du
géocentrisme de du monde clos du
cosmosclo à l'univers infini pour
reprendre le titre de la célèbre étude
de cohérer qui a signifié un
bouleversement cosmologique absolument
énorme et pour l'homme une perte de tous
les repères c'est à dire que là où
l'homme se sentait chez lui comme le
Diana rent dans un cosmos harmonieux
ordonné où chaque chose avait sa place
et où l'homme lui-même avait sa place il
se retrouve perdu comme un grain de
poussière sur une planète qui est
elle-même un grain de poussière dans un
univers infini et c'est une
désorientation absolument totale c'est
comme si le monde perdait son centre de
gravité l'homme d'un coup ne se sent
plus chez lui dans le monde et perd tous
les repères or où est-ce que l’homme va
retrouver ses repères à partir de quel
ancrage il va pouvoir reconstruire sa
vision du monde et donc
reconstruire un nouveau paradigme pour
employer ce terme cet ancrage il va le
retrouver en lui-même c'est comme ça
qu'on peut comprendre la trêve très
fameux je pense donc je suis de
Descartes première certitude que même
les plus extravagantes supposition des
sceptiques ne peuvent pas venir ébranler
premier rock solide point d'Archimède et
Descartes lui-même en parle dans ces
termes rock solide point d'Archimède à
partir duquel l'homme va pouvoir venir
reconstruire toute sa vision du monde et
c'est ça c'est le paradigme qui se
construit à partir de là qu'on peut
qualifier me semble-t-il de paradigme
moderne or qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
que l'homme reconstruit son paradigme à
partir de lui-même c'est-à-dire qu'il se
pose dans sa différence par rapport à
tout le reste à tout le reste du monde
et c'est peut-être là qu'on peut voir
si l'origine de ce qui va devenir la
crise écologique parce que du coup par
contre coup en miroir le monde et les
ressources naturelles mais y compris les
les animaux enfin tout le reste tout ce
qui n'est pas de la pensée tout ce qui
n'est pas le cogito va devenir pour
l'homme de la matière de l'étendue et de
une ressource exploitable à l'infini et
c'est ça qui ouvre peut-être la
possibilité même de ce qui va devenir la
crise écologique et aujourd'hui on est
donc avec la crise écologique face à une
crise globale de l'ensemble de ce
paradigme là
vous parlez de du sujet cartésien on va
dire plus globalement de l'homme la
question de l'homme est aussi ancienne
que la philosophie comment la reposer à
nouveau fruit qu'est-ce qu'elle a de
nouveau justement dans le paradigme
moderne alors oui la question de l'homme
est une question aussi vieille que
l'homme lui-même peut-être si vieille
que l'humanité néanmoins cette idée que
l'homme soit radicalement différent du
monde qui est d'un côté c'est la phrase
de Descartes pendant que je voulais
ainsi penser que tout était faux il
fallait bien que moi qui le pensais je
sois quelque chose on a d'un côté le
tout et de l'autre côté le moi et c'est
cette séparation là qui est très
nouvelle
l'homme c'est toujours interrogé sur sa
propre humanité et voilà mais quand
Aristote par exemple
définit l'homme comme un animal doué de
logos il ne le sépare pas du reste des
des êtres vivants il inscrit dans le
cosmos l'homme a une différence
spécifique par rapport aux autres et
qu'il est doué de logos mais néanmoins
il appartient au cosmos ce qu'il y a ce
qu'il y a de très nouveaux avec le
paradigme moderne c'est cette
distinction radicale entre l'homme et le
monde entre l'homme et le reste alors
vous montrez en même temps que à partir
du 17e siècle cette question de l'homme
elle se sent dans deux grands courants
en quelque sorte alors quels définition
de l'homme vont s'affronter et continuer
d'une certaine manière d'ailleurs de
structurer notre champ de pensée tout à
fait parce que
avec le cogito Descartes donne le coup
d'envoi de ce paradigme moderne qui va
se déployer à partir de lui donc et une
première ligne de force qui traverse la
modernité et il y en a une deuxième
qui est presque concomitante une
génération après Descartes on a un des
plus grands lecteurs de Descartes qui
est Spinoza et qui va précisément
contester ce qu'on peut appeler cette
différence ontologique que pose des
cartes entre l'homme et le monde et qui
va au contraire réinscrire l'homme dans
le tout dans ce qu'il appelle la
substance dans la nature et contester
l'idée que le cogito soit d'une nature
différente de tout le reste et donc
versus Spinoza ici
battle ouais et d'une certaine manière
Descartes et le père de la modernité
Spinoza aussi et le père de la modernité
mais d'une autre modernité qui est celle
qui consiste par la rationalité
scientifique à
inscrire l'homme dans le monde et qui va
contester justement cette séparation
radicale et c'est ça aussi la crise du
paradigme moderne c'est que on est on
est pris dans les tirs croisés de ces de
ces deux lignes de force et on ne peut
choisir ni l'une ni l'autre parce qu'on
est très attaché à l'idée que l'homme
soit différent des autres êtres qu'il
ait une dignité particulière qu'il est
qui mérite un respect absolu les droits
de l'homme et une certaine conception
juridique des droits des droits
subjectifs et d'un autre côté on est
très attaché aussi à toutes les études
scientifiques et à cette rationalité
scientifique qui convergent vers l'idée
que l'humanité est une forme d'être du
monde au même titre et parmi les autres
et c'est ce qu'on retrouve alors la
première conception celle qui distingue
l'homme du monde c'est celle qu'on
retrouve dans l'expression par exemple
quand on parle de l'humanité en l'homme
de l'humanité en l'homme qui lui donne
une dignité
particulière et puis la deuxième
conception celle qui est plus je dirais
héritière d'une filiation spinosiste
c'est celle qu'on trouve quand on parle
d'un animal humain ce qui veut pas dire
que l'homme se réduise à son existence
biologique Spinoza ne conteste pas que
l'homme est une rationalité mais en
revanche sa rationalité ne le met pas
sur un plan radicalement différent de
tout le reste et ça on est très attaché
aussi à idée que l'homme moderne se
serait mille lui-même sur un piédestal
de manière un peu arrogante et qu'il
faudrait l'en faire descendre donc on
est attaché à ces deux modernité à la
fois et elle est là aussi la crise et
c'est ça aussi qui fait que on ne peut
en sortir quand sortant du paradigme
lui-même et pas en alimentant une de ces
modernités contre une autre alors
comment on en sort
alors comment on en sort bah on ne peut
en sortir et là je vais encore suivre
quand mettant au jour ce qui fait la
racine de l'antinomie alors j'imagine
que vous allez me demander d'aller à la
source donc de cette antinomie il me
semble qu'elle est dans le fait d'avoir
caractérisé l'homme comme un être qui
pense
et qui serait de ce fait distinct et
radicalement sur un autre plan que tout
le reste il me semble que c'est là que
l'antinomie prend sa source d'une part
parce que
on peut tout à fait contester que la
pensée la raison ou la rationalité la
conscience de soi toutes les
manifestations de la pensée soit d'un
autre ordre justement que que dans
l'ordre naturel encore une fois quand
Aristote qualifie l'homme d'animal
rationnel ou d'animal doué de logos pour
autant il l'inscrit toujours dans
l'ordre du cosmos donc pourquoi est-ce
que le fait de penser mettre l'homme sur
un plan radicalement différent de tout
le reste d'autant que on a pu prouver
qu'il y avait une forme de pensée
que réserver le à l'homme le privilège
de la pensée et en faire le fondement de
sa dignité inaliénable du même coup ça
oblige
toute forme de pensée autre cumaines
pour moi il est là le nœud de
l'antinomie et c'est ça d'ailleurs qui
fait que il y a quelque chose de de très
nouveau aussi tu es qu'aujourd'hui la
question de l'humanité elle se pose
beaucoup à partir de ces marges et ça je
crois que c'est quelque chose de très
nouveau on a alors il y a je dirais deux
marges celles de la marge avec
l'animalité et la marge avec les
intelligences artificielles
voilà et j'en sors d'un côté comme de
l'autre on n'arrive plus il y a un
brouillage des frontières qui se fait et
effectivement
énormément d'études scientifiques
montrent qu'il y a des formes de
conscience de soi de penser de langage
même de culture chez d'autres espèces
animales et qui obligent du coup à se
réinterroger sur qu'est-ce que c'est que
le l'humanité si et puis de l'autre côté
avec le développement des intelligences
artificielles et puis toutes les
perspectives transhumanistes quand on
parle de transhumanisme on parle bien de
transe de dépasser quelque chose donc ça
oblige à définir la limite de ce que
c'est aussi que d'être un humain et donc
de ce côté-là aussi la question
d'humanité se pose à nouveau frais mais
à partir de ces marges et ça je crois
que c'est quelque chose de très nouveau
si la définition de l'humanité ou c'est
ce qui distingue l'humanité du monde ça
n'est pas la pensée puisque comme vous
venez de le dire la machine comme
l'animal pense en quelque sorte alors je
vais vous le dire de manière peut-être
un peu abrupte il me semble que ce qui
fait la différence c'est l'ouverture à
la transcendance
alors il va falloir nous expliquer ça
parce que c'est un retour religieux
est-ce que alors ça ça oblige évidemment
à
préciser ce qu'on peut entendre par
transcendance et il me semble qu'un des
grands écueils de la de la pensée
actuelle et de la philosophie
contemporaine et d'avoir un peu trop
vite évacuer la catégorie de
transcendance de la rationalité
philosophique d'avoir laissé la
catégorie de transcendance à la
théologie mais du coup de l'avoir évacué
du champ phénoménologique et là on
retrouve le titre de l'ouvrage que vous
avez été phénoménologie de la
transcendance et me semble être un mot
juste sur le phénoménologie pour
expliquer ça consiste enfin c'est une
méthode oui mais pour aller très vite
c'est il y a aussi une référence
ancienne dans cette méthode quand montre
que nous n'avons accès qu'à ce qu'il
appelle le champ de notre expérience
possible c'est le chant des phénomènes
de ce qui nous apparaît de à quoi nous
avons accès par la conscience et donc la
phénoménologie c'est l'étude de ce champ
de l'expérience possible on peut trouver
chez quand l'opposition à la
métaphysique qui justement va chercher à
avoir accès à ce qui est au-delà du
champ d'expérience possible donc la
phénoménologie ramène la rationalité
dans le champ de l'expérience possible
et vous montrer qu'on peut faire
l'expérience d'une certaine forme de
transcendance sans tomber ou sans verser
dans le mysticisme parce que tel n'est
pas du tout démonstration on ne peut pas
faire l'expérience de la transcendance
par définition puisque par défi alors
mais je reviens peut-être un instant
d'abord sur ce mot de transcendance
pourquoi la transcendance a été
abandonnée à la théologie parce que la
transcendance le terme même de
transcendance et c'est peut-être le cas
là où j'ai les les spectateurs en
entendant ce mot et tout de suite à
d'emblée associé à des notions connexes
et en particulier à la question de Dieu
voilà quand on dit transcendance à un
moment donné entre la bouche et
l'oreille de l'auditeur ça se transforme
quelque part en Dieu bah non là on ne
parle pas de Dieu on parle de
transcendance et puis la transcendance
est associée aussi à tout un tas de
superlatif transcendant c'est ce qui est
supérieur
lettre suprême un être suprême une
supériorité de puissance etc or
je crois que très souvent quand on veut
revenir au sens d'un mot vous savez il y
a cette il y a cette phrase de
vidgenstein que j'ai mise en exerg de
mon livre qui est parfois il faut
prendre un mot le retirer de la langue
et le donner à nettoyer pour voir le
remettre en circulation je crois que
précisément sur le mot de transcendance
il faut faire ce travail de le nettoyer
de toutes les autres notions qui se sont
sédimentées qui se sont greffés dessus
et sédimentés et pour ça on a un outil à
ce qui me semble qui est précieux qui
est le passage par les contraires
transcendant ça s'oppose à quoi est-ce
que ça s'oppose à inférieur non on dit
pas donc ça ne veut pas dire supérieur
est-ce que ça s'oppose à impuissant non
donc ça veut pas dire puissant donc à
quoi est-ce que ça s'oppose transcendant
ça s'oppose à immanent le mot de
transcendance prend son sens dans
l'opposition avec
cette autre terme qui est celui
d'imanence et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
immanent ça veut dire tout simplement
quelque chose qui est du même ordre que
du même ordre qu'autre chose et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire à l'inverse
transcendant ça veut dire être d'un
ordre absolument autre que
mais d'un ordre absolument autre ça veut
pas dire
surpuissance sur ça veut pas dire un
être suprême etc ça veut juste dire d'un
ordre autre et d'ailleurs c'est pas
forcément associé à Dieu d'ailleurs Dieu
peut être pensé comme immanent ou comme
transcendant on trouve dans toutes
sortes de théologie le panthéisme par
exemple est une manière de penser à un
dieu immanent et puis dans trouve aussi
des représentations d'un Dieu
transcendant donc il n'y a vraiment
aucune raison d'associer la notion de la
catégorie de transformation à celle de
Dieu et donc voilà et moi ce que je
propose ce que j'essaye de faire dans
mon travail c'est de décorer les les
deux pour pouvoir réintégrer la
catégorie de transcendance dans une
démarche strictement phénoménologique
ceci étant dit pour répondre à votre
question on ne peut pas faire
l'expérience d'une transcendance tout
simplement parce que par définition tout
ce dont on peut faire l'expérience et de
l'ordre de notre expérience donc
donc on ne peut pas faire l'expérience
de la transcendance
en revanche
on peut faire l'expérience
d'un monde on ne fait jamais toujours
que l'expérience du monde mais on peut
faire l'expérience d'un monde troué de
transcendance et c'est comme ça que je
propose d'appréhender la catégorie de
transcendance non pas comme une
surpuissance d'être mais comme un trou
comme une brèche ouverte dans l'être
et je crois que voilà cette brèche de
transcendance c'est ça c'est comme ça
peut-être qu'on peut caractériser le
cœur mais qui du coup est un coeur vide
vous l'aurez compris de ce qui fait de
l'humanité alors comment on pourrait
l'appliquer si on voulait l'imaginer
peut-être justement en revenant à la
question écologique
alors en revenant à la question
écologique bah je vais d'abord peut-être
essayer de donner un exemple mais qui
est pas directement lié à la question
écologique
la transcendance c'est donc l'ouverture
de la pensée à autre chose à ce qui est
absolument d'un autre ordre que le monde
et c'est à dire à quelque chose qui ne
renvoie à rien dans le monde quand on
dit par exemple tout simplement quelque
chose comme
respecte ton prochain
cette impératif là respecte ton prochain
ça n'est pas quelque chose c'est pas
comme si je dis ce fauteuil est noir ce
fauteuil est noir ça renvoie à quelque
chose dans le champ de mon expérience
respecte ton prochain c'est quelque
chose qui ne renvoie à rien à aucun être
à rien dans le champ de mon expérience
qui n'est pas démontrable
scientifiquement qui n'est pas
perceptible par l'essence et pourtant
c'est là bah
et ça appelle c'est comme un appel d'air
une aspiration un idéal qui appelle une
certaine forme d'action mais c'est cet
appel d'air que je propose d'envisager
sous la catégorie de transcendance donc
et mais c'est la même chose par exemple
on peut appliquer cette catégorie
également par exemple pour la création
artistique quand de face à un tableau de
Vermeer on est tout à coup saisi de
quelque chose qui nous transcende il
s'agit pas d'une puissance d'être ou de
on peut c'est un tableau de Vermeer ne
voir que des tâches de couleur c'est ça
si on en reste au champs de l'himalence
mais il y a quelque chose qui fait qu'un
tableau de Vermeer il n'est pas
réductible à ces conditions de
perception phénoménologique il ouvre
quelque chose dans l'être et c'est ça
que c'est ça que je propose d'appeler la
transcendance c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on trouve par exemple chez les Vinas
avec l'expérience du visage
qui n'est pas chez les vinasses
l'assemblage de il le dit de d'un nez
d'un front d'un manteau et Dieu il y a
quand je rencontre un visage je
rencontre quelque chose que je ne peux
pas saisir quelque chose qui n'est pas
de l'ordre de l'être quelque chose qui
n'est pas de l'ordre de la perception
quelque chose qui s'ouvre justement
voilà une brèche ouverte dans l'être
donc pour en revenir à la question
écologique pas déjà première chose ça
nous invite à repenser l'humanité en
sortant autrement que
dans cette tension entre animal humain
ou Transhumain parce que là parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est pris dans ce choix
cauchemardesque entre ces deux ces deux
formes d'humanité bah ça nous permet de
redéfinir l'humanité autrement et de la
redéfinir non plus en termes de progrès
ou d'accumulation de de
supériorité elle est toujours plus loin
toujours mais en termes précisément
d'une brèche ouverte dans l'être et ça
évidemment ça change complètement le
rapport
à l'autre homme le rapport au monde le
rapport aux animaux aussi parce qu'à
partir du moment où on ne loge plus
l'humanité de l'homme dans sa pensée à
partir de ce moment-là il y a plus aucun
problème pour reconnaître qu'il y a des
formes de pensée qui ne sont pas
humaines qui a des formes de pensée
animale des formes de conscience de soi
animal et qu'il faut les respecter comme
tel parce que ça ne remet plus en
question justement ce qui fait le cœur
de l'humanité donc ça change ça change
tout et donc évidemment voilà donc ça
ouvre je crois une porte de sortie de
cette crise de paradigme que nous
traversons alors on va terminer cette
entretien par quelques questions
quel est le rôle du philosophe dont la
cité est-il roi
ermite ou conseillé du prince
alors pour moi ni l'un ni l'autre ni
l'autre
si je devais
définir le rôle du philosophe dans la
cité
je dirais que le philosophe est un
briseur d'idole je crois que chaque
individu chaque génération chaque époque
à ses idoles et ses idoles c'est
précisément ces idées
devenu idoles figée en idole qu'on ne
l'interroge plus qu'on ne remet plus en
question ces idéologies voilà on voit
sans bien qu'il y a une proximité entre
idée idole idéologie il y a du coup dans
la philosophie quelque chose qui est
toujours à venir recommencer qui est
précisément de venir ébranler de venir
briser les idoles de son de son temps
ce qui fait que finalement
c'est quand même très paradoxal que le
père de la philosophie enfin Socrate
soit un homme qui n'est jamais rien dit
qui n'est jamais aucune doctrine qui
n'est fait qu'une chose qui est
justement de venir briser les idoles de
son temps de tout mettre en question il
l'a d'ailleurs payé assez cher voilà le
philosophe c'est un empêcheur de tourner
en rond donc il dérange il dérange il
n'arrête pas de déranger il est branle
et en même temps en empêchant de tourner
en rond bah du coup c'est lui aussi qui
permet d'avancer parce que pour avancer
il faut un moment donné être ébranlé
dans ces
dans dans ces certitudes il faut un
moment se trouver avancer ça veut dire à
un moment prendre le risque de
s'ébranler de se mettre en déséquilibre
pour pouvoir
aller vers autre chose et je crois que
c'est voilà je dirais que c'est
peut-être ça le rôle du philosophe dans
la cité si vous deviez citer le grand
livre de philosophie allez les pour être
généreuse c'est très compliqué ce que
vous me demandez mais juste du coup
peut-être que je vais le faire en lien
avec ce que je disais juste avant c'est
à dire que pour moi la
puissance philosophique d'un livre elle
est justement dans sa puissance
d'ébranlement qu'est-ce que le livre va
venir ébranler chez moi donc c'est
toujours aussi une rencontre parce qu'il
faut aussi être réceptif et ouvert il
faut pouvoir se laisser ébranler donc
voilà c'est très difficile de répondre à
cette question parce qu'il y a
différents moments ces différents textes
mais j'irai peut-être les les deux
préfacent à la Critique de la raison
pure de Kant non dans leur chronologie
le discours de les Méditations
Métaphysiques le premier livre de
L'Éthique de Spinoza et les deux
préfaces à la Critique de la raison pure
de Kant donc Descartes qui nous
acquantes le trio
comment pourriez-vous formuler question
particulièrement difficile en terme de
synthèse en une phrase la grande
question philosophique d'aujourd'hui
ça va peut-être pas vous surprendre mais
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui pour moi la
grande question c'est justement
d'arriver à se faire les gardiens de
cette brèche de transcendance ouverte
dans l'être
que représente l'humanité de se faire
les gardiens de cette brèche parce que
il y a rien de plus fragile et de plus
précieux qu'une brèche ouverte et si
elle se referme complètement si on ne
voit plus dans un tableau de Vermeer que
des tâches de couleur si on ne voit plus
dans un visage qu'un assemblage d'un
nez de très plastique alors là je crois
qu'on sera vraiment vraiment rentrer
dans un monde vraiment cauchemardesque
merci beaucoup